[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the agent program initiate
i'll be waiting for you inside follow
the lights please
majestic isn't it i'm diana
i'll take you to your quarters someone
likes to keep secrets
secrets are our stock and trade besides
from what i hear you have a few of your
own
i'm not like you in case you're
wondering i'm in the handheld program
agents and handlers work in unity you
know the expression
know your enemy well
that part is my job now your enemy is
only half the victory
i know you also need to know yourself
i'm working on it
i read your case file impressive work
hardly textbook but i suppose fieldwork
never is
tell me what did it feel like taking
lives
random disordered is that why you came
here
why you let us test you maybe i'm not
the only one
being tested well
we are here basic training starts at 600
hours
i should leave you to prepare
are you sure about this i am there are
no second chances miss burnwood
not here i choose him may i inquire why
a blank slate antisocial apathetic and
unresponsive
no doubt the boy shows promise but
perhaps i see possibility rather see
limitation
isn't that what a handler does sir we'll
see
anyone can kill miss burnwood he still
remembers nothing
if he does he's not sharing we will
check up on his story
the hospital in romania in the meantime
keep him under close watch
welcome to advanced mission training
this operation originally took place in
sydney
the target was calvin ritter infamous
cat burglar also known
as the sparrow you will need to
infiltrate the yacht
isolate and eliminate your target and
exfiltrate
all without arousing suspicion and
remember
as an ica agent you are the most
dangerous person in any room
but blunt force will get you nowhere in
this business and a true assassin
never calls attention to himself good
luck initiate
as previous tests have established you
exhibit
an unusual level of enhanced sensory
perception use your instinct now to
sense the position and movement of
people around you
and identify your targets
i suggest you do what you're told and
turn around
hmm that mechanic is in your way sneak
up and subdue him quietly
you put on his clothes that's a first
it might just work though people do tend
to see uniforms not faces
be cautious though some people are more
observant than others
not bad initiate before you move on
i suggest you hide your tracks you have
a much greater chance of success if your
actions go undetected
the toilet should do the trick be
advised initiate
ica clients rely on our discretion and
do not expect collateral damage
right they won't find him anytime soon
this particular uniform should get you
access through the staff entrance
just act normal
you're in well done initiate
right now for the tricky part start by
locating your target
intel suggests he's around the bar area
mechanic with his back turned he's what
we call an enforcer
he knows his crew and he'll see right
through your disguise so stay out of his
line of sight
we better make a mental note to strap
this thing down tight before we take off
right like this be ashamed my sister's
husband's got a model just like
unfortunately the place is crawling with
witnesses
i suggest you follow him see if you
can't isolate
hello
hmm
hey
mechanics if assimilation is the name of
your game
you'll need a better disguise
hmm
hmm
hey that's yours isn't it
well that's gonna leave a mark good
thing we have insurance okay
unlike mechanics the cabin crew is
allowed upstairs access
i see what you're getting at very
unorthodox
i like it
you have been compromised quickly try
and lose them and change your disguise
don't be a hard ass okay nobody wants to
get yeah
oh who's the big man now
oh your site was arrived
i'm being nice
okay unlike mechanics the cabin crew is
allowed
upstairs access i see what you're
getting at
very unorthodox i like it
the target's private deck now we're
getting somewhere
ah but according to intel ritter is
another enforcer who
picks his own cabin crew so tread
carefully
the target will spot you if you get too
close to eavesdrop on his conversation
try and find a way to blend in not die
you're not a snake already don't exist
blending in i see well done initiate
mr norfolk so good of you to fly down
can i offer you a drink oh no thank you
no
uh not before six my wife is
very insistent about that rule my
sympathies
so excellent timing i just had the
computer set up in my office
shall we yes please lead the way nice
impression
if we win you can fix me a drink anyway
sounds like ritter is about to have a
private meeting with the gentleman in
white
this could be useful greetings mayor
clearly it doesn't want to be disturbed
try sneaking around the back
get going
for a night
most of my clients are art collectors so
[Music]
any second now
[Music]
is
now is your chance use your silent
pistol or the
client will notice give me a second it's
just on the tip of my tongue
damn it almost headed
your target is down now head calmly
towards an exit
the red car marks your exfiltration
point simply push the button and you're
in the clear
advanced mission training complete and
may i say
elegantly done initiate i guess my hunch
was right about you
i look forward to the final test
how did you know i told you he had
talent
his stats are of the charts such skills
and
reflexes they could only be the result
of
previous training power like that with
no moral restraint
it could be dangerous i thought that was
rather the point sir
all agents have weak spots ms burnwood
pressure points to keep them in check
but this one
perhaps it would be better to just give
me a chance sir
give him a chance i will take full
responsibility
very well it's your show
[Music]
welcome back initiate as an ica agent
every challenge you face can be overcome
in multiple ways
complete this